Ich hab die Menschenwissen. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabenummer 48. Es geht voran, es geht voran, am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove. Und ich habe mir wieder ein neues Thema ausgedacht, völlig irrelevant für die Nachwelt, aber es hat mich einfach super interessiert. Nein, das ist Quatsch, es ist alles total wichtig für die Zukunft, denn es handelt sich um ein Betriebssystem namens FreeBSD, darum soll es heute Abend gehen. Und damit das Ganze auch etwas Inhalt bekommt, habe ich natürlich wieder Besuch dabei und zwar den Cryx.
Hallo Cryx.
Hallo Tim. Du bist ein FreeBSD-User, oder?
So kann man das sagen, ja.
Und wofür use du das?
Hauptsächlich benutze ich FreeBSD eigentlich für die Arbeit. Also ich bin halt Systemadministrator und ich glaube, ja, eigentlich alle Server laufen bei mir exklusiv mit FreeBSD, einfach weil es das Betriebssystem ist.
Wie viele Server sind das dann?
Ach Gottchen, wie viele Server sind das?
Weiß ich nicht.
Zwei Hände? Man kann sie nicht mehr an zwei Händen abzählen, auf jeden Fall.
Du weißt nicht genau, wie viele Server es sind? Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele es sind. Okay, also es sind einige.
Es sind einige.
Eine zweistellige Zahl.
Das sind ja, das sind nur die Server, das sind sozusagen nicht noch mal die virtuellen Jails, die da drauf laufen.
Okay, wo wir noch dazu kommen werden, aber um es vorwegzunehmen, ein einziger Computer dient nicht nur einem als Server, sondern es sind im Prinzip erstmal nur die Rechner und darauf laufen dann auch ganz viele verschiedene Server, die alle ihre eigene Konfiguration haben und voneinander separiert sind. Und was läuft da so alles? Also was surft das so alles?
Na einmal alles, vom Mail-Server zum Web-Server, zum FDP-Server, also eigentlich alles, was man heutzutage so im Internet an Services klicken kann, läuft da auf irgendeiner FreeBSD-Kiste als Service.
Und das sind dann Infrastrukturen von Firmen oder Privatleuten?
Das ist quer durch die Bank, Privatkram, also von mir oder von Freunden in einer Firma, Zeug oder für Kunden, halt irgendwelche Instanzen, die da laufen oder halt auch für den Club. So, die ganze Web-Infrastruktur und die ganzen Server für den Club laufen ja auch alle auf FreeBSD.
Alle?
Da laufen so ziemlich alle. Also alle unter meinen Fittichen sind auf jeden Fall FreeBSD. Und ich glaube, ein Großteil ist auch wirklich FreeBSD bei uns.
Einer dieser Server ist der Chaosradio-Server.
Ja, das ist auch ein FreeBSD.
Um den du dich kümmerst. Ist auch ein FreeBSD. Und ist auch einfach ein sehr schönes, ja, also ich finde den toll, weil der ist so schön stabil. Und ich habe mal selber einen FreeBSD-Server aufgesetzt im Jahre 2001. Das war noch FreeBSD-Version 2.0 irgendwas.
226 oder so was.
Und der lief dann und da liefen ganz viele furchtbare Sachen drauf. Da liefen Mail-Server drauf, Mailing-Listen, Web-Server, so. Und dann habe ich irgendwann mal aufgehört, mich um diesen Rechner zu kümmern. Und er lief und er lief und er lief und er lief und er lief, bis er irgendwann von einem anderen Server ersetzt wurde. Weil es war nicht mehr möglich, das System zu updaten, weil diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten, das war dann aber auch wirklich ein Problem, muss ich sagen, bei FreeBSD, zumindest an der Stelle, dass da irgendwie verschiedene Updates dann dazu geführt haben, dass sich die Subsysteme untereinander etwas incompatibel ergeben haben. Was auch immer der Grund dafür war. Aber was mich wirklich beeindruckt hat, war einfach diese unfassbare Stabilität, die damit war. Das Ding war immer schnell, das Ding war immer da. Und wenn es halt wirklich mal ein Problem gab, ist nicht so, dass der nicht stehen geblieben wäre, aber ich glaube, in den paar Jahren war das an einer Hand abzuzählen. So, es hatte dann auch immer noch irgendeinen Grund. Irgendwann ging das Ding dann mal in die Knie, ich glaube, weil da Webblocks draufliefen genau. Und dann ging das mit dem Webblock-Spam los. Also dann sozusagen drei Jahre danach. Dafür war er dann nicht mehr gerüstet, weil die Software einfach nicht aktualisiert wurde. Also wir haben jetzt gehört, ganz viele Server laufen beim CCC. Und der FreeBSD, Chaosradio läuft unter FreeBSD. Da muss man jetzt mal fragen, was ist denn eigentlich FreeBSD und warum nimmt man nicht was anderes?
Ja, FreeBSD ist erst mal ein quelloffenes Betriebssystem. Also die Quellen sind vollständig erhaltbar. Ungefähr so, wie es halt bei anderen offenen Betriebssystemen auch ist, die man so kennt, zum Beispiel Linux. Es ist ein offen entwickeltes System. Das heißt, die Entwicklung findet vollständig offen statt. Also der Prozess ist vollständig öffentlich. Man kann sich alles anschauen, was da passiert. Es gibt halt einen CVS-Repository, wo dieses FreeBSD komplett drin ist, wo man auch alle Änderungen am Source-Code sehen kann.
Ist das noch CVS tatsächlich?
Das ist zum einen Teil ist es noch CVS. Das ist der öffentliche Teil. Inzwischen sind die Developer intern auf ein Perforce umgestiegen. Und haben da ihre eigenen kleinen Abteile sozusagen.
Also es gibt da nicht diesen typischen Pfad. Also bei der Entwicklung heutzutage CVS ist ja eigentlich weitgehend von Subversion. Man hat sie eigentlich im Nachfolger auch abgelöst worden.
Die sind nie auf Subversion umgestiegen, die sind da immer noch bei CVS.
Okay. Und was heißt nicht öffentlich? Es hast du ja gerade gesagt, dass es sich um ein offenes System, also ein quelloffenes System handelt. Was heißt der nicht öffentliche Teil der Entwicklung?
Der nicht öffentliche Teil? Na ja, der ist schon öffentlich, weil man kann ja sich sozusagen alles angucken, was in diesem nicht öffentlichen, in dem Sinne heißt, dass es jetzt nicht in dem FreeBSD-Sourcecode eins zu eins wirgespielt wird. Also man muss sich halt vorstellen, die Entwickler haben halt sozusagen ihren eigenen kleinen Entwicklungsbaum, in dem sie halt Dinge ausprobieren, einchecken, daran rumbasteln und sozusagen ihre Tests damit da drin tun. Und erst, wenn diese Tests sozusagen einen gewissen Stabilitätsstatus erreicht haben oder einen Status erreicht haben, wo man sie wirklich in das große CVS einfliegen will, dann wandert es sozusagen rüber in dieses CVS.
So eine kleine Sandbox, wo die Entwickler rumschießen können, wie sie wollen.
Genau, so eine kleine Sandbox, sodass sie nicht irgendwie jetzt anfangen, in der South-Version, die die Leute sich wirklich auschecken, um die Leute halt wirklich rumzubauen und dann das Ganze sozusagen in einen instabilen Status bringen. Das sozusagen ist ein bisschen gewährleistet, dass das, was im CVS ist, wirklich auch einen lauffähigen Charakter einigermaßen hat. Also die Entwicklungsversion auf jeden Fall.
Das ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt. Vielleicht sollten wir auch nochmal darauf eingehen. Es gibt ja verschiedene Unterschiede zwischen FreeBSD und der sich aufdringende Vergleich ist natürlich immer Linux. Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch viele andere. Aber gerade im Vergleich zu Linux ist meiner Meinung nach die Entwicklungskultur, also die Art und Weise, wie zusammengearbeitet wird an dem Source Code von diesem Betriebssystem anders organisiert und offensichtlich auch mental irgendwie anders strukturiert. Das schlägt sich in vielen Details nieder, wie zum Beispiel erstmal grundsätzlich in der BSD-Lizenz. FreeBSD steht nicht wie Linux oder der GPL, sondern steht halt unter der BSD-Lizenz, die einfach einen anderen Heritage hat. BSD muss man dazu sagen, steht für Berkeley Software Distribution und ist eigentlich das Unix. Also das, was man heute meint, wenn man Unix, also nicht das, was man heute meint, wenn man Unix sagt, sondern das, was Unix immer war, das hat einige Pfade genommen von seinen ursprünglichen Entwicklern und einer der wichtigste Pfade, der vor allem fürs Internet wichtigste Pfade, ist halt der BSD-Pfade, der durch diese UCB, die University in California, Berkeley, gegangen ist. Und dort hat das Unix-IP gelernt. Und dort war ja dann auch irgendwann der Punkt erreicht, wo diese FreeBSD-Auskopplung stattgefunden hat. Hattest du den Zeitpunkt schon FreeBSD auf dem Radar?
Nee, zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich noch nicht FreeBSD auf dem Radar. Ich glaube, FreeBSD auf dem Radar hatte ich auch, so wie du gerade gesagt hast, so ungefähr 1991, 92, das erste Mal irgendwie. Weil vorher, ich meine, vorher war halt die Wende, und so alt bin ich dann auch noch nicht. Das heißt, da gab es das noch nicht.
Tja, ich kann mich doch noch daran erinnern, damals in Klondike.
Als wir nur Nullen und keine Einzen hatten.
So sah es aus. Ja, also ich meine, der Unix-Familientree, da gibt es ja so schöne Grafiken auch im Netz.
Ja, die verzweigen sich immer weiter.
So ein opulentes PDF, wo dann irgendwie auf 100 Seiten alle möglichen Verwandtschaften und Verwandtschaftsbeziehungen aufgezeichnet sind.
Alle haben von irgendwem irgendwas geerbt und immer weiter.
Genau, es ist ein riesiger Hrem, dieses ganze Unix. Und trotz alledem, um deine Rede kurz zu erinnern, BSD ist eigentlich sehr viel mehr ein Kind der ursprünglichen Unix-Entwicklung, während Linux zu einem Zeitpunkt neu geschaffen wurde und quasi Unix nur kopiert hat. Also genau so funktioniert, aber from scratch eine eigene Entwicklung war von Linus Torvalds und eben nicht mit dem alten Sourcecode gearbeitet hat. Und das zu einem Zeitpunkt, als es eigentlich kein freies Linus gab, nämlich eigentlich genau Ende der 80er Jahre, Anfang der 90er Jahre, wenn man Unix haben wollte, musste man sich eins kaufen, auch für die PC-Plattform, so Interactive Unix, SCO Unix. Das war alles zum gewissen Teil proprietär und mit Copyright hier und da. Aber die BSD-Linie von der Universität, die wurde dann halt irgendwie frei gemacht.
Ja, dann gab es dann verschiedene Patch-Sätze.
Die Teile, die umstritten waren, genau neu programmiert wurden.
Dann gab es diesen schönen Fall, dass sie da einige Teile hatten, die halt ersetzt werden mussten, weil die halt wirklich noch unter der AT&T-Lizenz oder was das war, gestanden haben. Dann haben sie sich da halt einfach mal zwei oder drei Tage hingesetzt und haben das einfach noch mal vom Scratch implementiert. Dann gab es halt wieder sozusagen ein neues Patch-Set, was dann vollständig frei war. Aus diesen ganzen kleineren Datchen stand ja dann da dieses i386-BSD. Und dann gab es diese Net-Patches. Aus den Net-Patches und diesem i386-BSD wurde dann so langsam dieses FreeBSD. Das kommt ja genau aus dieser Ecke raus.
Sollte man auch gleich noch dazu erwähnen, wir wollen jetzt vor allem über FreeBSD reden, aber es gibt ja in der näheren Familie auch noch ein paar andere Betriebssysteme, nämlich vor allem OpenBSD und NetBSD. Hast du mit denen auch schon mal Bekanntschaft geschlossen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe beide auch ausführlich benutzt. Ich habe zwei Jahre lang exklusiv NetBSD auf meinem Laptop-Computer benutzt, einfach weil es auch stabil und funktionabel war.
Auf was vor allem Laptop-Computer?
Das war irgendwie so ein IBM-Syncpad von vier Jahren oder so. Im Gegensatz zu dem FreeBSD-Support, das ist da schon der Soundchip, der da drin war. Und OpenBSD ist auf jeden Fall auch immer auf dem Radar. Und man kann auch gar nicht anders, wenn man ein FreeBSD benutzt, auch die anderen BSDs immer so ein bisschen auf dem Radar haben, weil es da natürlich auch Neuerungen und Innovationen gibt, die auch wieder ins FreeBSD rüber wandern und andersrum auch so. Also es gibt da immer zwischen den drei Haupt-BSDs, muss man ja sagen, es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr, sozusagen net, open und free, die erben ja voneinander immer so die Sachen, die gut sind oder die vernünftig sind, die werden da auch wild mit unter irgendwie kopiert und sportiert.
Und es ist ja auch immer so ein bisschen Competition, nicht wahr? So, wer hat den besten Kernel? Weil das ist ja schon mal so eine Eigenschaft. Alle haben dann doch noch irgendwie einen leicht anderen Kernel. Alle haben irgendwann mal mehr oder weniger mit dem gleichen System gestartet und hatten dann unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte.
Ja, sagt man so immer, man sagt halt immer.
Ja gut, aber NetBSD ist das am meisten portierte System.
Ja, das ist so der Fokus. NetBSD wäre das portierteste BSD.
Ist es das nicht?
Das ist es wahrscheinlich.
Doch, denke ich auch.
Also die Plattformliste ist lang.
Die ist länger als bei Linux.
Die ist länger als bei Linux. Es läuft auf wirklich groben Plattformen. Ich glaube, es läuft inzwischen auch auf Toasters. Und auch irgendwie so Network-Storage-Systeme. Da gibt es einen Blog, da tauchen dann jedes Mal wieder auf, dass es jetzt wieder ein neues Network-Storage-System oder einen neuen Drucker gibt. Und dann gucken sie in die Lizenzen. Dann steht da auch wieder drin, dass da ein NetBSD draufläuft. Also es ist halt wirklich massig portiert. Aber die Fokussierung ist halt auch nicht mehr so richtig eindeutig, weil auch FreeBSD auf vielen Plattformen läuft und OpenBSD auf vielen Plattformen läuft. Der andere Ansatz bei NetBSD ist halt irgendwie wirklich sauberen Code zu schreiben, der wirklich gut portierbar ist, weil sie sozusagen den Fokus da auslegen, was dann zur Folge hat, dass der Code auch relativ gut ist. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass der Code in FreeBSD irgendwie schlechter wäre oder so. Diese Fokussierung ist immer so ein bisschen, naja, das ist so ein bisschen so ein Vorurteil, muss man das eigentlich nennen. Weil auch bei OpenBSD sagt man immer, der Fokus wäre auf Sicherheit. Und natürlich sind die auf Sicherheit aus und die gucken, machen Resource-Code-Reviews und arbeiten daran, dass ihr OpenBSD sicher ist. Aber jetzt kann man auch nicht sagen, dass FreeBSD wesentlich unsicherer wäre als OpenBSD. Also alle Bugs, die im OpenBSD gefunden werden, werden auch im FreeBSD gefixt. Ist ja klar, weil ist ja alles offen.
Aber trotzdem sind es unterschiedliche Communitys?
Es sind unterschiedliche Communitys, obwohl es da auch Überschneidungen gibt.
Aber es gibt jetzt Regen-Sourcecode-Austausch zwischen den Systemen, aber es gibt fast keinen mit der Linux-Welt, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Ach, es gibt auch Austausch. Also es gibt auch Frameworks, die von Linux auf FreeBSD portiert werden. Und andersrum weiß ich das nicht, weil ich benutze halt nur die BSD-Seite, aber da kommen ab und zu auch mal Dinge von Linux rübergeschwappt ins BSD.
Aber das braucht ja dann die passende Lizenz.
Ja, aber da haben ja die BSD-Leute nicht so das Problem mit der Lizenz. Also sie haben ja nicht das Problem, dass sie eine Lizenz haben, die vorschreibt, dass es quelloffen ill bleibt, sondern sie haben eine Lizenz, die da wesentlich öffener ist. Und da kann sozusagen im Source-Tree auch was mit GPL drin sein, ist gar kein Problem. Das funktioniert ja.
Aber nicht umgekehrt?
Nicht umgekehrt, genau.
Das heißt, BSD kann quasi von Linux profitieren, aber nicht zwingend ohne weiteres andersrum? Was mir dazu noch einfällt, warum auch, du meinst, so net BSD läuft ja auch auf fast jedem Scheiß, also eine, ein Nebeneffekt dieser BSD-Lizenzen, und du sagst ja, sie ist offener, also die Diskussion ist ja immer so, was ist jetzt freier? Richard Stormen sagt natürlich so, naja, nur GPL ist frei, weil die GPL ist viral und sichert ihren eigenen Erhalt so, und niemand kann das irgendwie wegnehmen. Was natürlich auch dann häufig dazu führt, dass Firmen das gar nicht erst einsetzen. Und die haben eben den Vorteil bei BSD, dass sie den Soundscoot nicht veröffentlichen müssen, wenn sie nicht möchten.
Leider so gar nicht. Lustigerweise setzen die Firmen trotzdem den Linux-Gram ein und fallen damit dauernd auf die Nase, dass sie den Linux-Gram einsetzen.
Ja, dann kommt Harald und klagt sie weg.
Klagt sie weg, genau.
Genau, aber bei BSD kann ihnen das halt nicht passieren, weil da steht nicht, dass sie den Soundscoot veröffentlichen müssen.
Genau, aber diesen Gedankenschritt, den gehen sie ganz oft nicht und denken da gar nicht drüber nach.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein anderes Problem. Aber es gibt durchaus Firmen, die das tun. Wir müssen noch ein weiteres BSD, was sehr populär ist, erwähnen, nämlich Darwin. Die Grundlage von Mac OS X von Apple ist auch eine BSD-Variante, die nochmal ein bisschen anders ist, weil sie ja dann auch diesen Machkörner mit drin haben, aber die sich auch eine ganze Menge co-teilen, vor allem, glaube ich, mit FreeBSD, aber auch von NetBSD hier und da. Sie haben sich halt auch über das ganze User-Land die Tools noch mit dazu nehmen. Also im Prinzip gibt es vier große BSDs derzeit, Free, OpenNet und Darwin, die alle...
Muss man noch Dragonfly-BSD dazu sagen.
Was macht das?
Dragonfly-BSD ist ein Offspring von FreeBSD4. Wir sind ja bei FreeBSD jetzt inzwischen beide, FreeBSD6 bzw. FreeBSD7 dann hoffentlich demnächst. Und es gab sozusagen einen Offspring, der sich dann nennt Dragonfly-BSD. Und der Fokus von Dragonfly-BSD sind so Cluster-Systeme. Also sie wollen es wirklich schaffen, so einen BSD vernünftig auf mehrere Computer zu verteilen und das als sozusagen transparentes System zu bieten.
Dass ein Programm einfach automatisch auf mehrere Computer läuft.
Genau, und da sind sie gerade dabei, dafür auch nochmal ein extra Dateisystem zu schreiben, weil es ja auch nicht so ganz einfach ist.
Also mit anderen Worten, es gibt auch dort eine Menge Aktivität noch. Also es ist beileibe keine tote Plattform.
Es wird immer belächelt. Dieses Forken wird immer belächelt. Jetzt wieder ein neues FreeBSD. Man forkt FreeBSD und nennt es anders und fängt wieder an, eine ganz andere Richtung zu entwickeln. Und viele Leute sagen dann halt, da werden ja Ressourcen verschwendet, weil da wird das Rad mehrfach erfunden. Und da geht ja irgendwie Manpower verloren. Und bisher muss man einfach sagen, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Weil wenn man sich zum Beispiel so Dinge wie OpenBSD anguckt, was ja sozusagen Fork von NetBSD ist, haben die Leute, die sozusagen OpenBSD angefangen haben, Theodor Rath, die haben da durchaus auch eigene Sachen und neue kreative Sachen geschaffen. Sozusagen in einem anderen Zweig, von dem jetzt die alten BSDs nochmal wieder profitieren, weil natürlich da wieder Innovation dazu gekommen ist. Und bei Dragonfly-BSD wird das auch genau der gleiche Fall sein. Da werden jetzt neue Sachen entwickelt, in eine neue Richtung gegangen, der Fokus ein bisschen verschoben und in eine andere Richtung. Und auch die Innovationen, die daraus entstehen, werden natürlich irgendwie wieder zurückfinden ins FreeBSD, ins NetBSD oder ins OpenBSD.
Ja, da zeigt sich jetzt auch nochmal so ein grundsätzlich... Wie soll ich sagen? Also, was ich vorhin schon meinte, die Communities funktionieren anders als bei Linux. Das würde ich ganz gerne mal so vergleichen. Man ist es so gewohnt jetzt aus der Linux-Welt, dass man sein Betriebssystem konsumiert als sogenannte Distribution. Das heißt, da gibt es eine Firma, und diese Firma tut im Prinzip nichts anderes als allen möglichen kleinen Kram an Source Code, natürlich vor allem auch den Kernel, aber eben auch was noch sonst zum Betriebssystem dazugehört. Richtig, oder Community, also Organisationen irgendeiner Art, die sammeln das dann zusammen, ballern das zusammen und sagen, okay, das ist jetzt hier unser Release von einem System, na ja, was wir jetzt mal irgendwas Linux nennen. Und dann würde natürlich wieder Richard Stormen anfangen zu schreien und sagen, nein, das ist ja genug Linux und überhaupt, ja. Also diese Melange aus Körnern und was halt noch dazu gehört, das wird dann eben so released. Das heißt, die Leute, die mir mein fertiges Betriebssystem zusammenstellen, schreiben es eigentlich nicht. Während bei BSD, korrigiere mich, wenn ich es falsch zusammenfasse, aber das ist mein Verständnis, dass das gesamte Betriebssystem eigentlich aus der Developer Community heraus released wird und dann gibt es eben auch genau ein Release.
Es gibt da halt dieses CVS und das ist das FreeBSD.
Da ist halt nicht nur der Kernel dabei, sondern...
Das ist das komplette System. Also während das bei Linux ja so ist, dass der Kernel in einem Repository sozusagen gepflegt wird von einer Entwicklergemeinde, wobei die Entwicklergemeinde von Linus Torvalds sozusagen geleidet, muss man ja sagen. Also er hat sozusagen den letzten Schliff, macht dann Linus Torvalds. Also er committet halt Sachen in den Kernel, in den Linux-Kernel. Er ist der Committer. Und das führt halt dazu, dass bei den ganzen Distributionen, wenn die sozusagen so einen Kernel haben, wenn die mit dem Kernel nicht zufrieden sind, der sozusagen aus dieser Entwicklung des Linus Torvalds herausfällt, dann gibt es sogenannte Patch-Sets. Und diese Patch-Sets sind halt von Distributor zu Distributor sind die unterschiedlich. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mal wieder ein SUSE Linux installiere, habe ich halt den SUSE-Linux-Kernel, der basiert auf dem Linux-Kernel, aber da sind garantiert irgendwelche Patch-Sets drin. Es sind andere Treiber drin, da sind Sachen rausgepatcht, weißte er gar ja. Wenn ich mir einen Debian-Linux installiere, dann ist das wieder der Linux-Kernel mit anderen Patch-Sets, weil die halt einen anderen Fokus auf freie Lizenzen haben. Da sind dann halt Dinge rausgenommen aus diesem Kernel. Und das ganze User-Land, was sozusagen zu diesem Linux gehört, das stammt nochmal ganz woanders her. Das verwalten sozusagen die Distributoren bei sich selbst. Man kann also nicht sagen, dass jetzt der Source-Code von ls in jedem Linux der gleiche wäre. So, da sind immer vielleicht andere Patches drin, die irgendwelchen anderen Kram machen oder irgendwas anderes. Es gibt sozusagen kein einziges bestimmendes Repository, aus dem so ein Linux besteht, also so eine Linux-Distribution. Jeder Distributor hat sein eigenes CVS. Und beim FreeBSD gibt es halt genau nur dieses eine CVS. Und das, was in diesem CVS drin ist, das ist auch das FreeBSD und das landet darin auch in den ISO-Files oder auf den CDs, die ausgeliefert werden, die man sich bestellen kann. Und es gibt halt kein anderes. Es gibt nicht noch mal ein tralalala FreeBSD.
Und welches Modell findest du besser und warum?
Na, mir gefällt natürlich das FreeBSD-Modell wesentlich besser, weil es halt einfach dafür sorgt, dass es einen Repository gibt, eine Community, die sich um dieses eine Betriebssystem kümmert und daran halt arbeitet und das zu einem Gesamtprodukt sozusagen bringt. Und ich kann mir halt irgendwie das CVS angucken und ich weiß genau, was los ist. Ich kann mir halt angucken, welche Releases da drin sind und welche Änderungen da vorgenommen sind, warum sie da vorgenommen sind. Und ich muss mir nicht mal ins Horse Code irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Quellen zusammensuchen von der Distribution, die ich benutze oder von der Distribution, sondern ich check mir einmal dieses CVS aus und habe mir den kompletten Source Code des kompletten Betriebssystems in der Hand.
Man hat also auch mehr Augen auf dieser Integration. Man kann natürlich sagen, das eine ist ja nur der Kernel, das andere sind ja nur die Programme und so. Und das kann man zusammenklatschen, wie ich möchte. Aber die Abhängigkeiten sind ja dann nicht immer ganz ohne und werden dann unter Umständen bei so einer Distribution, wo eben nicht so viele Augen sich jetzt darum kümmern, übersehen, sowas?
Ja, also dazu muss man jetzt sagen, dass die FreeBSD-Entwicklergemeinde vielleicht nicht von der Größe her nicht so groß ist wie die gesamte Linux-Entwicklergemeinde. Aber bei denen teilt sich das dann halt auf die Distro-Toren auf, während beim FreeBSD sozusagen ein Team gibt.
Wie groß ist dieses Team?
Also es besteht ja hauptsächlich aus dem Core-Team. Das sind so ein paar Leute, die da reingewählt werden, aus der aktiven Entwicklergemeinde, aus den Leuten, die commit access auf dieses CVS heran.
Wie häufig werden die gewählt?
Die werden, glaube ich, alle zwei Jahre gewählt. Und die sind halt dafür zuständig, dass sozusagen dieses FreeBSD in eine bestimmte Richtung gelenkt wird oder die Entwicklungsziele in eine bestimmte Richtung gelenkt werden. So was wie, wir müssen jetzt mal irgendwie unseren IP-Stack irgendwie schneller kriegen und deswegen fokussieren wir jetzt unsere Bemühungen darauf, den schneller zu kriegen. Oder bestimmte Leute im Core-Team konzentrieren sich halt darauf auf ein Themengebiet. So was wie, wir machen jetzt mit den Ports. Oder ich kümmere mich jetzt um die Ports, dass sie in Ordnung sind. Und der Rest besteht eigentlich dann nur noch aus Leuten wie den Committern, also Leute, die wirklich Commit-Access auf das CVS haben, die da wirklich schreiben können, und den Benutzern. Und das war es eigentlich auch schon. Das heißt, es ist eine relativ einfache Hierarchie. Es gibt da halt eine Gruppe von Menschen, die sozusagen, na wie nennt man das, repräsentativ gewählt sozusagen sind von den Committern. Und dann gibt es nochmal die Userbase. Und das war es dann sozusagen auch schon.
Also so eine dreistufige Hierarchie in der Community. Aber nicht eine Hierarchie im Sinne von, dass die einen wirklich jetzt über den anderen stehen, sondern jeder kümmert sich einfach um was anderes. Das Chor-Team kümmert sich eigentlich um den Code des Kernels, des einigen Systems.
Na das machen die ganzen Committern. Alle Committern kümmern sich darum.
Das Chor-Team entscheidet aber darüber, wohin die Reise geht.
Wohin die Reise ungefähr geht. Es setzt sozusagen die Richtung vor, aber es muss nicht die Umsetzung sozusagen sein.
Verstehe, also es ist mehr so eine, ja, fast so sagen wir mal, mit den Personen, die man in dieses Chor-Team wählt, bestimmt man im Prinzip auch die Politik, wohin es gehen soll.
So ungefähr, ja. Also kann man so sehen, dass natürlich, wenn da Sichten die Weltoppa hinsetzt, der nicht im Chor-Team ist und da unglaublich ein Code irgendwie runterreißt, der total toll ist, dann wird der nicht weggeworfen oder so, sondern es wird sich halt auch angeguckt, dann wird das auch irgendwie importiert.
Gut, ja, das ist doch schon mal ein guter Einstieg, so zu sehen, wie jetzt eigentlich auch die Philosophien da eine andere sind, weil ich habe immer wieder beobachtet, dass sowohl bei den Leuten, die jetzt dafür programmieren, aber auch bei den Leuten, die es halt auch nur benutzen, so eine BSD-Anhängerschar irgendwie anders drauf ist als eine vergleichbare Linux-User-Group. Weißte nicht, was du da so für Beobachtungen gemacht hast?
Es gibt da, da wollen wir natürlich auf Linux nicht rumbaschen, aber es gibt da immer so lustige Ansätze, wie dann jetzt der typische FreeBSD-Entwickler aussieht. Und da gibt es dann so einen lustigen Spruch, dass der typische FreeBSD-Benutzer sich 4 oder 5 Jahre in seiner Teenagerzeit im Linux ausgetobt hat und dann zu FreeBSD gewechselt ist, nachdem er einigermaßen erwachsen geworden ist. Und man muss auch wirklich, also wenn man jetzt auf so eine BSD-Konferenz geht, dann ist der Altersdurchschnitt schon ein bisschen höher als in so einer Linux-User-Group. Hab ich zumindest so den Eindruck. Es sind viele Leute, die aus dem akademischen Umfeld kommen. Und die sind alle immer ein Stückchen älter, als man das jetzt so annimmt. Und sind beim Unix auch alle schon ein bisschen länger dabei, als jetzt irgendwie vor drei Jahren.
Das ist ja das, was ich eigentlich auch schon gesagt habe. Das ist halt auch ein Projekt, was ja schon seit 1970 einfach läuft. Man nimmt ja, sagen wir mal, dass Unix, also Linux hat natürlich auf jeden Fall erheblich dazu beigetragen, Unix als solches überhaupt auf die Rechner und in die Herzen zu kochen.
Das muss man einfach hoch anschreiben.
Es ist extrem erfolgreich und in gewisser In-Sicht mag auch dieses Distributionsmodell dazu beigetragen haben. Es ist einfach auch Leuten die Möglichkeit, bietet ein System zurechtzuschneidern für einen bestimmten Zweck. Ohne jetzt zu tief Zugriff und Einblick haben zu müssen.
Das ist natürlich auch Flexibilität. Auch als Firma dahinter zu stehen und dafür vernünftigen Support zu leisten. Das ist ja auch immer so ein Argument. Kann ich mir jetzt dieses Betriebssystem installieren? Kriege ich davon irgendjemanden Expertise? Kriege ich das Support? Das ist ja auch immer so eine Frage.
Aber trotzdem ist halt das Linux-Phänomen noch relativ neu. Also eigentlich kann man sagen, ich weiß nicht, wann das so angefangen hat, ich habe so den Eindruck gehabt, so der Impact von Linux, das ging so Mitte der 90er Jahre, 1995, 1996 ging das irgendwie los. Und ja, so um 2000 war es natürlich dann auch der totale Hype. Jetzt beruhigt sich das wieder ein bisschen besser. Mit der New Genau, da war ja alles eigentlich der totale Hype. Aber wie schon gesagt, Unix war zu dem Zeitpunkt halt schon immer da. Und ich kenne halt auch Leute, die schon in den 80er Jahren an Unix mitprogrammiert haben und Code bereitgestellt haben. Und das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch so ein bisschen die Garde, von der du gerade sprichst. Die also einfach für die Linux was Neues war dann irgendwann mal. Ah, jetzt gibt es auch noch das Interessant.
Da gibt es auch noch Linux.
Genau. Also wir bewegen uns hier in der Diskussion bei Unix, beim guten alten Unix. Und FreeBSD, kann man sagen, ist heute eigentlich von diesen vollständig freien Systemen, mit Abstand das populärste, oder? Kann man das sagen?
Also die Userbase ist bei BSD, glaube ich, schon der größte Teil des FreeBSD. Da gibt es noch eine schöne Webseite, die heißt www.bsdstats.org. BSD Stats ist so ein Stückchen Software, was man sich installieren kann, was jeden Monat meldet, hallo, ich bin ein BSD, ich habe folgende Version, ich habe folgendes software installiert. Und da kann man relativ gut sehen, wie da so die Verteilungen sind.
Oh, das ist aber überraschend. Da müssen wir ja gleich noch über was anderes reden. Und zwar ist hier Platz 1 FreeBSD mit 48,6% und Platz 2 ist PCBSD. Was ist das denn?
PCBSD ist ein nur FreeBSD-basierendes Desktop-System sozusagen. Sie haben da FreeBSD einmal als Grundstein genommen, das aktuelle FreeBSD 6.2, und bauen oben drauf einen End-User-Destop. Jetzt, glaube ich, KDE benutzen sie. Kann auch sein, dass sie da Gnome benutzen. Die Philosophie ist einfach sozusagen CD brennen, CD einschieben, Booten installieren, fertiges Desktop-Betriebssystem. Das, was man von Linux auch mit Knoppix zum Beispiel kennt. Also ein fertig konfiguriertes Desktop-Betriebssystem.
Und es wird auch derselbe Desktop verwendet. Also es gibt jetzt in der BSD-Welt kein eigenes Desktop-System.
Nein, da gibt es kein eigenes. Das ist KDE, Gnome, was man sich halt installieren will.
Das sind ja erstaunliche Zahlen. Also das heißt, PC, BSD, keine Ahnung, sind die aussagekräftig hier diese BSD-Stats? Also 10.000 Rechner scheinen mir jetzt in der Summe nicht sehr viel zu sein.
Nein, das sind natürlich nur die, die sozusagen dieses BSD-Stats-Programm sich installiert haben aus den Ports. Das heißt, alle anderen, die das nicht installiert haben, zum Beispiel Google wahrscheinlich, die sind da nicht mit drin. Deswegen sind da 10.000 Rechner wahrscheinlich ein bisschen wenig zu sein.
Google hast du gerade gesagt?
Ich glaube, Google benutzt auch noch FreeBSD. So wie Microsoft ja bei Hotmail auch FreeBSD benutzt und verschiedene andere große Firmen auch FreeBSD einsetzen, ohne da jetzt groß gar Geld drum zu machen, weil die Admins da schon immer FreeBSD eingesetzt haben.
Okay, NetBSD, OpenBSD ist hier, zumindest in dieser Liste, ein bisschen unterferner liefen. Aber man sieht, es gibt hier auch noch verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen auf das Dragonfly, was du noch erwähnt hast. Das kann man gar nicht lesen. MidnightBSD?
Das ist glaube ich auch ein FreeBSD Offspring, genauso wie dieses Desktop-BSD.
Die brauchen erst mal ein Logo, was man auch gut lesen kann, glaube ich. Gut, jetzt hast du ja eingangs schon erwähnt, du setzt es für viele Systeme ein. Und jetzt kann man natürlich das ganze Development-Modell mögen, oder dass die Programmierer zehn Jahre älter sind im Durchschnitt. Am Ende zählt aber dann doch eigentlich das Endergebnis. Die Leistung, die Performance, die Security. Und es ist ja auch schon klar geworden, sowas wie FreeBSD auf dem Desktop zu verwenden. Das ist dann schon eher so für die Leute, die eigentlich sonst auch mit BSD arbeiten. Und wenn sie dann mal bunt klicken, hätten sie halt auch ganz gerne dasselbe Betriebssystem darunter. Man läuft jetzt nicht zu einer BSD-Distribution, wenn man nach einem Desktop-System sucht. Wir reden eigentlich hier von einem Server-Betriebssystem. Das ist das, wo FreeBSD seine volle Stärke zum Einsatz bringt. Genau, so. Und du hast ja schon gesagt, du deckst da mit den Systemen, die du administrierst, eigentlich die volle Bandbreite an Diensten ab. Was macht es denn jetzt sozusagen so reizvoll da? FreeBSD, also was hält dich jetzt konkret davon ab? Oder was hält dich davon ab, was anderes zu machen ist? Die falsche Frage. Was sind sozusagen die schicken Sachen, die FreeBSD dir jetzt bietet, sodass du sagst, okay, ich fühle mich gut hier mit meinen Serverchen. Was sind so denn die Sachen, die du jetzt erwähnen würdest? Warum sollte man FreeBSD auf seinem Server einsetzen?
Na, es gibt verschiedene Gründe. Also erstmal ist es aufgeräumt, wie wir schon eben gesagt haben. Also es befinden sich halt alle Sachen da, wo ich sie erwarten würde im User-Land. Ich kriege den Source Code relativ einfach und komplett. Ich muss mir den zusammensuchen.
Das heißt, es gibt so einen Server und da kommt irgendwie das große Image und dann ist das einfach das Release und fertig?
Das ist das Release, genau. Dann kann ich es mir nochmal auschecken und die ganzen Sources aktualisieren. Genau, es ist relativ einfach zu aktualisieren. Da halt alles aus einem CVS kommt, kann ich mir die neueste Version oder wenn es Updates gibt, einfach per CVS auf meinen Server runterladen, da alles neu compilen, es installieren. Es ist eine Sache von einmal compilen, wie schnell der Computer ist, und dann einmal Make Install wird und Make Install Kernel sagen. Dann habe ich das aktuellste BSD mit allen Security-Patches und was ich so brauche. Es ist sehr, sehr einfach. Es ist ungefähr so einfach wie bei einem Betriebssystem zu sagen, wir upgraden jetzt mal hier und installieren mal alles. Das ist ein großer Vorteil. Es bietet mir so tolle Dinge wie Jails, um sozusagen verschiedene Zonen zu schaffen, um verschiedene Software zu installieren, die voneinander getrennt ist.
Gefängnisse.
Gefängnisse, genau. Und es bietet mir eine Firewall, die jetzt von OpenBSD gekommen ist, die ziemlich feature-complete ist und die performt. Was gibt es noch? Ja, es gibt die Ports, es gibt eine riesige Software-Kollektion.
Okay, ich denke, das müssen wir mal ein bisschen hinterfragen. Dieser Podcast ist jetzt sowieso schon an einem Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo es wahrscheinlich überflüssig ist, darauf hinzuweisen, dass wir ein sehr technisches Thema haben heute. Trotzdem nochmal versuchen, vielleicht das eine oder andere auch... Es ist nicht immer einfach, sowas zu übersetzen, aber nichtsdestotrotz wollen wir das mal probieren. Ich meine, nun ist natürlich Server betreiben, not for everybody, aber es gibt ja diesen Bedarf in zunehmenden Maßen. Ich mag das auch an mir. Man sitzt zu Hause, man hat hier einen Rechner dafür, hier einen Rechner dafür, Leser, Drucker, alles prima. Aber dann merkt man, wenn ich jetzt mal ordentlich E-Mail haben will, oder ich brauche mal ein Wiki, ich möchte gerne mein eigenes Blog laufen lassen, dann muss man immer losgehen und sich den Adminen des Vertrauens suchen. Den findet natürlich nicht unbedingt jeder. Und so richtig einfach aufzusetzende Server-Systeme sind dünn gesät. Ich kenne da eigentlich relativ wenig. Ich weiß, Apple probiert das so ein bisschen mit Mac OS X Server. Das ist aber auch nicht ganz billig. Wenn man also jetzt kostengünstig losmaschieren will, ist ja FreeBSD auf jeden Fall eine Wahl. Vielleicht machen wir das ja mal so rum. Ich hätte jetzt gerne meinen Heim-Server. Was kann ich jetzt tun? Wir spielen das einfach mal durch mit FreeBSD. Wie würde ich da vorgehen? Was brauche ich? Wie würde man so ein System aufbauen? Wie spielen diese Sachen, die du jetzt gerade erwähnt hast, die Ports, die Gefängnisse und so damit rein? Also ich brauche einen Blog und ich brauche irgendwie einen Wiki und ich brauche irgendwie Mail.
Erst mal Computer kaufen, was?
Was kauft man da so?
Na ja, da kauft man heutzutage halt, was man so kriegt. Eine Ahnung, Intel-AMDs, läuft da auf allen möglichen Kram. Dann kauft man sich da ein bisschen Speicher und vielleicht so zwei Festplatten.
Also ich muss mir jetzt nicht irgendwie einen speziellen PC, der auch mit FreeBSD läuft, sondern eigentlich...
Nein, der Treibhaus-Support ist für heutige Computer eigentlich ausreichend, dass man den Laden gehen kann, jetzt mal von einem Serverbetriebssystem, dass man den Laden gehen kann, sagen kann, geben Sie mir diesen Computer und dann installiert man dann ein FreeBSD drauf und dann funktioniert die Netzwerkkarte und funktioniert auch irgendwie der Plattencontroller und die Festplatten, wenn er kann. Und es wird auch eine Konsole auf der Grafikkarte geben und das tut alles. Das heißt, wir gehen in den Laden und holen uns halt einen Rechner und kaufen den halt irgendwie mit beliebiger CPU von Hersteller, den wir gerade mögen, halt irgendwas, keine Ahnung, es könnte jetzt auch ein Spark-Server sein, aber... Gut und billig. Gut und billig, also nehmen wir halt einen i3-86-Server und kaufen uns da einen mit einer Intel-CPU oder einer AMD-CPU, was wir halt haben wollen, wo wir die Präferenzen haben, schleppen den nach Hause.
Platten rein.
Platten rein, ISO runterladen, auf CD brennen.
Also ISO runterladen, du meinst ein Image von einem CD.
Ein CD-Image runterladen, genau.
Das heißt, das brenne ich mir auf eine CD, die stecke ich da rein und sage GO.
Dann sagst du GO und dann...
Dann kommt das Bund hoch und sagt, hallo, ich bin...
Es kommt einigermaßen bundhoch, es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie eye-candy-mäßig, also es ist jetzt nicht superbunt, es ist ein relativ simpler, einfacher Installer, der einen nicht mit irgendwelchen Kramen überschwemmt oder jetzt besonders schick gemacht ist, sondern er ist funktional gehalten. Und dann gibt es auch für Leute, die das nicht so oft machen, gibt es halt einmal Step-by-Step-Installieren, also Platten formatieren.
Gibt es dann irgendwelche Literatur, die man zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon heranziehen sollte?
Da könnte man ins FreeBSD Handbook gucken.
Oh, du bist gerade alles runter hier.
Das ist mein Telefon. Dann könnte man ins FreeBSD Handbook gucken. Das kann man sich entweder als Papierausgabe noch zu den CDs mitbestellen, wenn man sie denn bestellen möchte, um sozusagen FreeBSD was Gutes zu tun. Oder man könnte sich das jetzt auf einem anderen Rechner im Web angucken, da gibt es das. Das kann man auch in Deutschland angucken.
Das Handbook ist im Prinzip so die Referenz. Das ist so das Handbuch.
Das ist das Handbuch. Das ist das FreeBSD-Handbuch.
Das ist auf den Servern von freebsd.org und es gibt nur dieses eine.
Es gibt nur dieses eine. Es wird auch im CVS gepflegt.
Aber das ist jetzt mehr als so ein Referenzmanual. Das ist schon so ein bisschen das, was jetzt in der Linux-Welt von How-To's abgedeckt wird. So wie gehe ich vor, wenn?
Mehr. Also das Handbook erklärt wesentlich mehr. Es erläutert sozusagen auch die Hintergründe, was man da jetzt eigentlich tut. Es gibt nicht nur Commandlines, die man sozusagen eins zu eins abtippt, ohne zu erklären, was die jetzt eigentlich tun. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel im Handbuch nachgucken würde, wie partitioniere ich meine Festplatte, dann wird vorher erst mal erklärt, Festplatte besteht aus Zylindern und aus Blöcken und funktioniert so und so und taucht im System so und so auf und wird dann formatiert. Und was ist denn eine sinnvolle Art und Weise zu entscheiden, wie man Festplatten formatieren würde? Es wird sozusagen nicht gesagt, du musst das so und so machen, sondern es wird nur erklärt, was wäre eine gute Idee zu machen oder was sind sozusagen die Ansätze, wie man seine Festplatte...
Das heißt, man muss jetzt nicht unbedingt schon der totale Admin-Experte sein. Man sollte vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen Feinkontakt gehabt haben mit Unix in irgendeiner Form, aber wenn man jetzt...
Es erleichtert das auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist natürlich alles keine leichte Materie, aber wenn man generell da offen ist, meinst du, kann man mit dem FreeBSD-Handbook auf jeden Fall auch die Grundlagen parallel...
Ich glaube, mit diesem FreeBSD-Handbook kann man erstens die Grundlagen sicherarbeiten. Ich glaube auch, es ist ein sehr guter Einstieg in die Unix-Welt überhaupt. Also alle, die sozusagen mit Unix noch nie irgendwelchen Kontakt gehabt haben, kann ich dieses Handbook nur wärmsten empfehlen, weil da halt auch so ein kleiner Einstieg in Unix drinne ist. Und da ist relativ gut erklärt, wie sozusagen dieses Konzept Unix funktioniert und wie man das sozusagen behandelt.
Okay, gut. Und das kann man sich aber auch im Print irgendwo organisieren.
Das kann man sich im Print, kann man sich im Buchladen kaufen oder online bestellen oder halt man hat sowieso das CD-Image sich runtergeladen und klickt das halt an und da ist es halt nochmal in HTML-Form drauf und kann es in seinem Browser einfach angucken.
Okay, das heißt jetzt habe ich irgendwie meinen Server und ich habe meinen FreeBSD Handbook aufgeschlagen auf meinem Laptop oder auf meinem Tisch. Und ja, und dann geht es los. Dann installiere ich das alles. Und setze das so auf und dann bin ich fertig und alles super.
Das ist natürlich noch nicht alles super. Dann habe ich noch keinen Blog und dann habe ich keinen Web-Server und keinen Mail-Server, nichts gar nichts. Das ist dann die Stelle, wo sozusagen die Supports Collection einspringt.
Genau, was ist das eigentlich?
Supports Collection ist eine Sammlung von, man sagt immer so schön, Metadaten. In diesen Metadaten steht ja nichts weiter drin, als ich möchte eine Software herunterladen, ich möchte eine Software installieren, ich möchte sie in folgender Version haben.
Von welcher Software reden wir jetzt? Die eigentliche Betriebssystem-Software mit den ganzen Tools, was man erwartet, ist ja dabei.
Anwendungssoftware, Datenbanken, Web-Software.
Also wie zum Beispiel meine Blog-Software.
Genau, die sind da alle drin. Die sind nach Kategorien sortiert. So was wie eine Kategorie wie Mail oder eine Kategorie wie www. Wo man dann halt in www. sowas findet wie ein Web-Server oder aber auch ein Browser. Alles, was halt mit dem World Wide Web zu tun hat. Oder in einer Kategorie Mail halt ein Mail-Server oder ein Mail-Client. Sozusagen thematisch geordnet. Und da kann ich dann sozusagen reingehen und einmal sagen, Make Install und dann holt er sich, das steht halt in diesen Metadaten drin, von einem Server, der zu diesem Port gehört, holt er sich den Source-Code und fängt an, den zu compilen.
Das heißt, das sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen, so ein FreeBSD macht auch irgendwie alles im Source-Code.
Also, ich krieg nicht nur ganz viel.
Also ich hab natürlich, wenn ich mir dieses ISO-Image runterlade in CD-Brenner, dann hab ich natürlich einen näher ausführbaren Betriebssystem. Das kann ich reinstecken und booten. Installieren und dann ist das auch alles, da muss nichts übersetzt werden. Aber ich kann.
Du kannst das komplette System nochmal übersetzen.
Das heißt, auf dieser CD ist auch schon der ganze Source Code dabei?
Der Source Code ist auch da drauf. Von dem vollständigen Betriebssystem.
Also alles, was ich da installiere, ist in dem Sinne gleichzeitig auch schon als Source Code da. Und normalerweise ist der Ansatz jetzt so, wenn ich irgendeine Software neu installiere, dann übersetze ich mir die auch aus dem Source Code heraus?
Das kann man tun, ja.
Das kann man tun oder das tut man in der Regel?
Also ich tue das in der Regel.
Aber man kann es sich auch binär laden?
Ja, als Package sozusagen vorkompiled liegt es auf der CD auch nochmal rum. Oder man holt es sich auch nochmal aus dem Internet. Also diese Ports Collection, diese Sammlung von Anwendungssoftware, die sozusagen nur in Metadaten vorliegt und dann erst anfängt zu kompilen, die gibt es auch nochmal in sozusagen einmal fertig kompiled als binäres Paket, das ich mir nur noch installieren brauche, nichts mehr kompilen kann.
Warum sollte man das jetzt dann noch selber übersetzen?
Unter Umständen ist man halt mit den Konfigurationen, die beim Kompilen übergebbar sind, nicht zufrieden. Zum Beispiel möchte man jetzt zum Beispiel nicht, dass irgendein Tool mit grafischen Bibliotheken noch verlinkt wird. Dann kann man halt in der Ports Collection sagen, ok, mach mir mal eine Konfiguration, lass mal den ganzen Trödel da weg, kompilier mir das mal mit ganz anderen Optionen. Diese vorkompilierten Pakete haben ja immer den Nachteil, dass irgendjemand entschieden hat, dass er das so und so kompiliert, und dann ist es kompiliert, und dann installiere ich mir das fertig kompiliert, und dann hat das halt die Option, und dann muss ich halt damit leben. Das hat halt auch bestimmte Abhängigkeiten zu anderen Bibliotheken oder anderen installierten Paketen. Und dann muss ich die auch alle so nehmen. Wenn ich in die Ports Collection gehe, kann ich halt sagen, ich möchte jetzt aber nicht, dass da irgendwie die grafischen Bibliotheken mit kompilt werden, dass die da mit reingelinkt werden. Oder ich möchte ganz andere kompilierte Optionen. Weil man zum Beispiel auf dem Server nicht braucht.
Das heißt, es würde zu viel Platz wegnehmen?
Ja, zu viel Platz. Oder es würde auch nochmal die Komplexität des Systems erhöhen. Oder ich weiß halt, dass ich da nie irgendwelche grafischen Sachen brauche.
Kann man die Software dann für den Prozessor, den man hat, direkt optimieren?
Kann man auch nochmal optimieren, obwohl das meistens auch nicht so viel bringt. Also bei normaler Anwendungssoftware bringt das jetzt nicht so super viel. Vielleicht bei Bibliotheken nochmal irgendwo.
Ok, das heißt, ich habe jetzt meinen Rechner installiert. Und sagen wir mal, ich habe mir jetzt so die Software ausgewählt. Dann greifen wir jetzt hier mal zu den Klassikern. Ich brauche WordPress für meinen Blog. Ich will MediaWiki für meinen Wiki. So, das ist ja alles bodenständig heutzutage schon. Bei Mail wollen wir am besten gar nicht erst mit der Diskussion anfangen, was man dann nimmt. Oder hast du noch eine Empfehlung?
Ich schweige.
Das ist eine der schlimmsten Diskussionen. Also wir empfehlen euch hier heute keine Mailsoftware. Da hat jeder seine andere Religion. Aber du kannst trotzdem sagen, was du vielleicht einsetzt. Oder setzt du auch mehrere Sachen ein?
Ich setze mehrere Sachen rein.
Country und Western.
Das kommt immer auf das Anwendungsgebiet an.
Okay, alles klar. Und auf den Kunden sozusagen. Genau. Aber bleiben wir trotzdem bei dieser Software. Jetzt habe ich mir das irgendwie installiert. Und jetzt würde ich ja normalerweise so hergehen, dass ich da so einen Webserver habe. Dann konfiguriere ich da halt meinen Blog und meinen Wiggi mit rein. Jetzt hast du von Gefängnissen gesprochen. Wer kommt da rein?
Na, ins Gefängnis kommt alle die rein, wo ich will, dass sie ins Gefängnis kommen. Dazu muss man vielleicht erstmal erklären, was sozusagen der Sinn von diesen Gefängnissen ist. Also von diesen Jails, diesen Nominösen. Es ist sozusagen eine Art Virtualisierung. Also Virtualisierung ist ja inzwischen in aller Munde. Liest mal überall, dass die Prozessoren sozusagen Virtualisierung unterstützen, dass man sich dann vor MWR installieren kann oder auf dem Mac Parallels, wo man Gastbetriebssysteme drin laufen lassen kann, die man eventuell braucht, aus Sicherheitsgründen oder einfach aus Gründen, dass man die Software auf dem eigentlichen Betriebssystem, auf dem Rechner, nicht laufen lassen kann. Und Jails ist sozusagen so eine quasi Virtualisierung. Man kann da jetzt keinen Linux drin installieren oder einen Windows oder so, aber man hat da sozusagen einen FreeBSD drin.
Das heißt, das ist nicht ein komplett neuer Computer, sondern es ist eine komplett neue Instanz von dem sowieso schon installierten Betriebssystem.
So ungefähr, ja. Also die Prozesse laufen nicht nochmal auf einem eigenen Kornel, sondern sie laufen in dem normalen Kornel mit, allerdings abgeschottet von den anderen Prozessen.
So, als wären sie alleine auf dem Computer?
So, als wären sie, genau, sie sehen sozusagen nur die Prozesse im Jail, sehen sozusagen nur sich selbst und nicht die Prozesse außerhalb von den Jails oder in anderen Jails.
Das heißt, jedes kleine Gefängnis hat dann auch seine eigene IP-Adresse und so weiter, und man kann einen Computer nehmen und betreiben, als hätte man mehrere.
Genau.
Und das ist alles schon so mit dabei?
Und das ist alles schon so mit dabei. Und das gibt's auch schon echt lange, das gibt's seit, was mich lügen, seit FreeBSD 4, vielleicht auch schon seit FreeBSD 3, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Also ein paar Jahre?
Es gibt's schon ein paar Jahre und es gab da natürlich auch Bugs, dass man da ausbrechen kann und die sind inzwischen hoffentlich dann doch so ziemlich alle gefixt. Aber es ist abgehangenes Zeug, also diese quasi-Virtualisierung gibt's halt schon länger als vor allem wer länger als diesen ganzen anderen Kram, den's da gibt. Ist halt nicht so mächtig, weil man kann halt kein anderes Betriebssystem dran laufen lassen, aber ein FreeBSD, man hat sozusagen viele kleine FreeBSDs auf einem Haupt-FreeBSD. Und es gibt dann verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Man kann zum Beispiel sagen...
Das ist auch mit separaten Benutzern?
Mit separaten Benutzern und allem. Also man muss sich das vorstellen, wer sich schon mal in so einen Unix eingeloggt hat, vielleicht per Remote-Login, der kriegt da ja eine Shell und kann irgendwie Prozesse sehen und Dinge tun. Und wenn er sich in so einen Jail einloggt, dann sieht es genauso aus, wie als wenn er sich in ein ganz normales Unix einloggt, mit Prozessen, mit einer IP-Adresse. Und das funktioniert alles ungefähr genauso.
Gibt es irgendetwas, was ich in einem Jail nicht tun kann? Was ich sonst so, wenn ich...
Es gibt keinen Local-Host. Es gibt keine Loopback-Interface. Das ist auch noch ein Nachteil, den sie hoffentlich dann bald mal irgendwann angehen. Und ein Jail hat immer nur eine IP-Adresse. Das ist auch noch ein Nachteil. Aber ansonsten funktioniert eigentlich so gut wie alles da drinnen. Es reicht locker für Dinge aus, wie, ich möchte jetzt einen Mailserver installieren, ich möchte einen Web-Server installieren. Und ich weiß genau... Und ein Wiki in diesem Web-Server, sagen wir mal. Und ich weiß genau, dass jetzt dieses Wiki nicht so der tolle Software-Hit ist. Und es hat immer mal Security-Fehler und Bugs. Und ich möchte lieber auf die Situation mal sicher gehen und möchte nicht, dass die Leute, die dann meinen Web-Server aufmachen, auch noch meine Mail lesen können. Weil die halt in dem Server mit drin liegen. Und dann geht man halt her und nimmt sich zwei JLs und startet die und hat sozusagen nochmal zwei FreeBSD-Instanzen, die voneinander getrennt sind und vom Hauptsystem auch getrennt sind. Und installiert sich in das eine JL den Web-Server mit dem Wiki und das andere JL die Mail mit dem Mail-Server. Und hat zwei AP-Adressen, wie auch immer, und hat sozusagen diese beiden Installationen voneinander getrennt, vollständig. Und wenn jetzt jemand in den Web-Server einbricht, kann er die Mail nicht lesen. Und wenn jemand auf den Mail-Server zugreift, dann...
Solange die Gefängnisse ausbruchsicher sind.
Solange die Gefängnisse ausbruchsicher sind, was viele versucht haben, halt auch schon zu brechen und da viel ins House Code geguckt wurde. Und also die Sache ist halt wirklich schon ganz schön abgehangen. Garantiert gibt es irgendwo Bugs. Gibt es immer, ich meine, aus Paravirtualisierungen wie Paralysen und vor allem werden so die Leute auch schon ausgebrochen.
Nichts ist sicher. Ach, es ist eine furchtbare Welt.
Nichts ist vollständig sicher. Sicherheit ist ein Prozess im ganzen System.
Wie heißt das schon im Fernsehen immer? 100%ige Sicherheit kann es nicht geben. Oder wird es nicht geben. Und dann schauen sie immer so ganz fassungslos, als wäre das Schlimmste, was einem überhaupt passieren könnte auf diesem Planeten, dass es 100%ige Sicherheit nicht geben kann. Aber es ist eine schöne Standardfloskel. Jetzt auch bei Chaosradio Express. Okay, das heißt, wir haben da so Gefängnisse. Und das ist sozusagen der Top-Hit bei FreeBSD.
Na, was heißt der Top-Hit? Also es ist ein sehr gutes Feature, was ich als Systemadministrator prima einsetzen kann, weil ich halt einen Server habe, den ich mir aufteilen kann in verschiedene kleine Server und die Prozesse voneinander trennen kann und die Administration auch meinetwegen an andere Leute abgeben kann, die wirklich nur in diesem Jail die Software verwalten. Und es gibt mir halt die Möglichkeit, auf einem Server viele Server laufen zu lassen.
Und so als Obersitz-Admin sitzt man eigentlich auf dem eigentlichen Hauptsystem?
Da sitzt man auf dem Hauptsystem und kann von da aus halt in den Jails werkeln und tun, wie man will.
Und kann ja so ein bisschen betupsen, wenn er einen Prozess durchdreht und so, dann schraubt man eben einfach irgendwie die CPU ab.
Genau, dann tötet man den weg oder fragt halt den Admin, der dieses Jail verwaltet, was das eigentlich da soll.
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt so 30 Rechner administrierst, wie sieht das dann bei dir zuhause in der Wohnung aus? Hast du dann so 10-30 Zoll-Bildschirme an der Wand, wie man das so kennt?
Nein.
Master-Control oder wie behältst du da den Überblick?
Ich habe ein MacBook und so aus. Also ich habe, früher hatte ich mal viele Rechner, hatte einen ganzen Küchenschrank voll gehabt, aber inzwischen habe ich eigentlich bloß noch einen Plaster-Router im Schrank stehen und meinen MacBook auf dem Schoß.
Aber du schläfst gut, also du hast jetzt irgendwie nicht den totalen Terror, also ich weiß, so ein einziger Server kann einem schon schlaflose Wochenenden bereiten, wenn der irgendwie zu wackelig ist. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt irgendwie mit einer zweistelligen Zahl Server agiert, dann...
Ja, wenn die Hardware streikt und irgendwie der Rechner immer abstürzt, dann hat man da halt ein bisschen Trouble mit, dann muss man sich um die Hardware kümmern. Aber das FreeBSD gibt mir eigentlich da wirklich am allerwenigsten Kopf zerbrechen, weil das läuft halt einfach und ist stabil und...
Problematisch sind dann eher die Dienste, die neinander laufen.
Genau, eher die Dienste. Also es gibt da halt diese Ports und in jedem Jail sind dann halt um, keine Ahnung, 20 Ports installiert, was man halt so braucht und Abhängigkeiten. Und dann hat man halt da schnell mal 200 Softwarepakete auf einem Server, auf die verschiedenen Ports verteilt und da ist dann pro Woche muss man da bestimmt immer mal eins updaten. Und da gibt es aber wiederum in den Ports sozusagen Utilities, die mir einmal die komplette Übersicht über die in den Jails installierten Ports gibt und ob sie jetzt irgendeine Security-Problem haben oder nicht. Das ist nämlich auch so eine schöne Sache an dem Portsystem. Da gibt es auf freiwilliger Basis mehr oder weniger gibt es eine Datenbank, wo sozusagen eingetragen wird, dass dieser Port ein Security-Problem hat.
Die gibt es im Internet?
Die gibt es im Internet und da gibt es ein Tool, das heißt sich Port Audit, nennt sich das und diesen Port Audit gibt man sozusagen den Namen des Ports mit der Versionsnummer, die immer hinten dran hängt und dann sagt es einem, ob in dieser Datenbank ein Security-Problem zu diesem Port drinne steht. Und wenn ja, gibt es halt sozusagen eine Meldung aus, dieser Port hat folgendes Problem und unter dieser URL findest du eine genaue Beschreibung. Und dieser genaue Beschreibung ist halt sozusagen der Angriffsvektor erklärt und der Patch und der Fix und die verschiedenen Bezeichner, die es in den verschiedenen Security- Datenbanken haben. Da gibt es ja so verschiedene Security-Datenbanken, wo so Security-Probleme gelistet werden. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel so 20 Gels auf einem Rechner habe, da habe ich mir halt selber irgendwann mal einen Port geschrieben. Ich bin sozusagen ein sogenannter Port-Maintener, der sich um einen Port kümmert und der selber Software geschrieben hat. Und der nennt sich Jail Audit und der geht sozusagen alle installierten Ports in jedem Jail durch, wirft dir diesen Port Audit vor und guckt halt, ob es da ein Security-Problem gibt.
Also er testet das dann auch?
Er testet sozusagen, geht für alle Ports, die in allen Gels installiert werden. Guckt danach, gibt es da ein Security-Problem.
Also schaut er jetzt nur, welche Versionsnummer das ist?
Das ist ja nur ein String, den er sozusagen rausfüllen muss.
Nein, nein, nein.
Der guckt die nur alle durch, wirft dir der Datenbank vor, guckt halt, ob es da Probleme gibt und generiert daraus eine Menge. Und die kriege ich dann und dann habe ich einmal am Tag die Übersicht, welche Probleme gibt es auf dem Server, welche Ports müssen geupdatet werden, damit sozusagen die Security-Probleme wieder weggehen. Und das ist ein relativ mächtiges Tool, weil man halt auf einen Blick sieht, okay, auf dem Server sind der, der und der Port oder die, die und die Software hat gerade ein Problem. Und dann setze ich mich halt ran und sage halt den Admins Bescheid, die entweder einen Jail bei mir haben, dass sie sich darum kümmern, oder ich sage dem Tool, die sollten ihnen gleich die Mail schicken und update halt die Ports in den verschiedenen Jails. Und bin da dann immer relativ gut mitgefahren, dass die Software relativ schnell geupdatet wird und ich da keine Software habe, die Security-Probleme hat.
Also ich höre schon so ein bisschen raus, diese Jails sind aber schon so the way to go. Das ist jetzt nicht so eine Option, die man so mal nehmen könnte oder so, sondern das ist eigentlich schon der Ansatz.
Für einen Cyberbetrieb, also für mich, in meinem Einsatz und auch an den Leuten, die ich kenne, die FreeBSD als Cyberbetriebssystem anwenden, sind Jails definitiv eines der mächtigen Werkzeuge, die auch viel benutzt werden. Das ist auf jeden Fall.
Gibt es da noch weitere mächtige Werkzeuge, die der Erwähnung wert sind?
Da gibt es, na Ports sind auf jeden Fall auch ein Werkzeug. Aktualisierte Software, die Jails. Dann gibt es noch die Firewall, die ein mächtiges Werkzeug ist, die aus OpenBSD portiert worden ist. Das ist PF.
Was ist an dir so mächtig?
Die Packetfilter, die hat alle Features, die man in der Firewall haben will.
Das ist ja ein bisschen allgemein die Beschreibung.
Ja, na klar, Filtern, Port-Forwarding, dann gibt es da relativ schnell beim Regeln durchgehen, was bei der Firewall immer sehr wichtig ist, damit sie sozusagen nicht den Netzwerkverkehr ausbremst. Ja, was gibt es da noch alles? Jede Menge. Also die Firewall ist halt einfach komplett, sie deckt alles, was man mit einer Firewall machen will, deckt sie sozusagen ab.
Also mit anderen Worten, man kann so ein FreeBSD auch jetzt auf Firewall-Ebene sichern, ohne dass man da jetzt noch irgendeinen Add-On benötigt. Man kann sie auch erforschen, man kauft da kein Firewall-Produkt dazu oder installiert nochmal irgendeine Firewall-Software, sondern das ist einfach mal Teil des Betriebssystems.
Oder man setzt das FreeBSD gleich als Firewall ein. Das geht natürlich auch. Also als Router, der nochmal Firewall ist. Die Anwendungsbeispiele gibt es ja auch.
Dass man nochmal so eine Maschine vorschaltet.
Genau. Nicht nur als Serverbetriebssystem, sondern auch als Routerbetriebssystem.
Gibt es denn kommerzielle Firewall-Systeme, die auf FreeBSD basieren, von denen du weißt?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Kann man nicht ausschließen, weil sie müssen es ja auch nicht sagen, wenn sie es tun?
Genau. Sie müssen nur im South Scots zuschreiben. Sie dürfen die Lizenz da oben nicht entfernen.
Das ist ja das einzige, was nötig ist.
Die Credits müssen da bleiben.
Das ist ja übrigens auch das, womit seinerzeit die Universität, also die Berkeley University, gegen AT&T vorgegangen ist. Weil, als sie da irgendwie angefangen haben, ihre Software zu verteilen, an die Studenten und so, kam dann irgendwann AT&T an und meinte so, unser Copyright, und was macht ihr denn da? Da ist ja unser Code drin, ihr verteilt das. Und dann war so Pullen so ein bisschen offen und dann wussten sie nicht so richtig, was sie tun sollten. Aber dann haben sie halt irgendwie festgestellt, dass AT&T auch dieses Unix mit Änderungen, die sie wiederum hinzugefügt haben, an andere Kunden verkauft hat, wo dann auch diese Copyright-Message nicht ausgegeben wurde. Dann war das so ein bisschen Waffengleichstand und daraufhin hat sich dann die Sache etwas entspannt. Also, ich finde ja die BSD-Lizenz irgendwie geil. Weil die ist so, die ist einfach so gnadenlos frei. Also, das hat vorhin schon so angedeutet, so dieses, was ist jetzt die Freiheit? Also, die Gnu-GPL und Richard Stormen sehen halt irgendwie die Freiheit in, ja, der Code, wenn er einmal da draußen ist, der muss dann auch frei bleiben. Deswegen zwingen wir bestimmte Regeln wiederum auf, wie man mit dieser Software umgehen kann. Das BSD-Verständnis, also das ist auch das, was ich immer aus Gesprächen, wenn ich mit Leuten aus der BSD-Kommunikative rede, die sehen einfach das Wort frei in einer ganz anderen Bedeutung, die eigentlich sehr viel mehr von der persönlichen Freiheit her geprägt ist, dieses, ja, jetzt habe ich diese Software bekommen und ab jetzt kann ich machen, was ich will.
Das eine ist halt die Freiheit des Codes und das andere ist eher so die Freiheit der Anwendung. Und so ein BSD ist halt, kann ich halt machen, was ich will mit, ich kann es kompilieren und irgendwo hinwerfen, ich kann es verkaufen, ich kann damit sonst irgendwas machen, solange sozusagen diese Credits der Developer, die daran geschrieben haben, dabei sind, ist das alles kein Problem, wenn man halt bei Linux sozusagen alle Änderungen müssen wieder zurückgeführt werden, der Code muss immer frei bleiben, ich kann daran nichts ändern oder ich kann es nicht verkaufen.
Es ist ja immer, also so ein Standardvorwurf an der Stelle ist ja, dass es nicht dazu führt, dass der Source Code, wie soll ich sagen, dass also wirklich der Source Code, dass die Leute, die das benutzen, dann auch nicht dazu beitragen. Ich weiß nicht, was du da so für Sichtweisen entwickelt hast. Also klar, eine Firma kann das jetzt einfach nehmen, sich schön bedanken und sagen irgendwie...
Das kann sie tun....
alles prima.
Also da haben auch schon viele Leute darüber nachgedacht und das ist ein sehr interessanter Gedanke, dass natürlich jetzt eine Firma sagen kann, ok, ich nehme jetzt irgendwie dieses BSD und ich mache da jetzt Änderungen dran und dann verkaufe ich das. Und das ist auch alles schön und gut und das können sie auch gerne machen. Das stört keinen weiter. Da geht jetzt FreeBSD nicht so viel bei verloren, weil die Änderungen hätten sie wahrscheinlich so oder so nicht von denen bekommen. Aber die Firma hat das ganz einfach das Problem, dass sie sozusagen immer mit dem aktuellen FreeBSD standhalten muss und der Entwicklung des aktuellen FreeBSD standhalten muss. Und das ist relativ anstrengend bei einem Betriebssystem, wo relativ viele Leute daran arbeiten und wo die Innovationsgeschwindigkeit relativ hoch ist. Das heißt, sie müssen immer wieder aus dem aktuellen FreeBSD die neuen Features in ihr Produkt übertragen. Und das ist wirklich anstrengend. Das kostet halt viel Manpower, das zu tun. Und da ist es für die eigentlich einfacher zu sagen, okay, bezahre jetzt mal Entwickler und die machen das. Die entwickeln dieses Feature, was ich als Firma brauche, und gebe denen das jetzt einfach wieder zurück zu FreeBSD. Und dann ist es da drin und dann entwickeln andere daran weiter und dann kann ich einfach das FreeBSD mal nehmen und das Feature, was ich brauche, ist einfach immer mit drin.
Und viele Leute kümmern sich darum, dass es auch mit den anderen Änderungen im Kern auch immer noch weiter funktioniert.
Das passiert auch tatsächlich. Da kommen dann halt Firmen, die kaufen sich halt Developer und bezahlen die dann halt mal drei Monate, dass sie einen Feature in FreeBSD reinhacken. Und dann gibt es das Feature in FreeBSD und dann sind alle glücklich.
Ein anderes Subsystem, von dem viel die Rede war, ist dieses Geom-Subsystem, was die Art und Weise, wie das Betriebssystem mit den Festplatten umgeht, geändert hat. Gehört das auch zu diesen Dingen, die vielleicht häufiger zum Einsatz kommen, weil sie eine Menge Arbeit abnehmen können?
Ja, natürlich. Mit Festplattenhandchen muss man als Admin dauernd und man muss ja auch irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass die Daten gesichert sind. Und wenn die Festplatte ausfällt, nicht alles weg ist. Und dieses Geom, dieses modulare Disk-Minagement oder Disk, weiß gar nicht, wie es jetzt Geom war, glaube ich, nicht mal eine Abkürzung, sondern steht einfach für sich.
Steht das System nicht für so Geometrie? Ging es nicht um Daumen?
Na, es heißt eigentlich Modular.
Gucken wir doch mal hier, die allwissenden Müllhalter.
Stopft den Kopf nicht voll mit Fakten, sonst ergibt es Akten.
Nö, hier steht auch nichts, was es heißt. Es heißt einfach so. Ja, was macht es denn?
In diesem Geom ist sozusagen jede Festplatte oder jedes Pfeil ein sogenannter Provider. Und diese Provider kann ich untereinander verknüpfen, wie ich möchte.
Erstmal Big Picture. Was ist Geom? Geom ist alles, was mit Festplatten zu tun hat.
Alles, was mit Daten speichern. Also alles, was mit Datenträgern zu tun hat.
Ok, also grundsätzlich meiner Floppy Disks.
Genau, deine Floppy Disks ist sozusagen dein Geom-Provider, deine Festplatte. Dein USB-Stick könnte ein Geom-Provider sein. Und diese Provider kann man untereinander schachteln.
Warum geht es jetzt? Also ist das dieses Prinzip des Poolings, dass man jetzt, ich habe ganz viele Orte, da könnte man mal was drauf speichern, aber wie das dann alles zusammengeht, das konfigure ich dann später?
Das ist mehr modular gedacht. Man kann sozusagen eine Festplatte machen und kann dazwischen einen Layer tun, der mir das alles, was auf die Festplatte geschrieben wird, komprimiert. Und dann kann ich da drüber noch einen Layer machen, der alles, was auf die Festplatte geschrieben wird, verschlüsselt. Oder ich mache mir einen Layer dazwischen, der alles, was auf dieses Device geschrieben wird, eigentlich ins Netzwerk schreibt oder im Netzwerk als Device anbietet. Ich kann das alles übereinander layern und kann das beliebig miteinander kombinieren. Da kann man relativ einfach so Dinge machen, wie sich einen RAID zusammenbauen. Also zum Beispiel so ein Viror.
Also im Prinzip so ein LEGO-Kasten.
Ein Baukastensystem.
Ein LEGO für Festplatten.
So ein LEGO für Festplatten-Fu. Man kann zum Beispiel sagen, nimm mal diese beiden Festplatten und mach mir da jetzt mal den Mirror draus. Also alle Daten, die in dieses Device reingehen, also mein Mirror-Device, dieses Geom-Device, werden auf beide Festplatten geschrieben. Und schon habe ich einen ganz normalen RAID-Mirror.
Aber nach oben sieht das aus wie eine Festplatte?
Nach oben sieht es aus wie eine Festplatte. Und ich kann darauf sozusagen operieren, wie als wenn es eine ganz normale Festplatte wäre.
Und das Dateisystem, das da drauf ist, muss nichts davon wissen?
Das Dateisystem muss nichts davon wissen, genau. Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Entwicklungen. Da kann man sich halt ausdenken, was man will. Zum Beispiel halt Module, die man dazwischen tut, die das komprimieren oder verschlüsseln. Oder Journaling machen zum Beispiel. Gibt es jetzt, nennt sich G-Journal, sozusagen ein Modul, was einen Journaling-Log, egal für welches Dateisystem oben drauf ist, macht sozusagen darunter ein Journaling.
Also Journaling ist das so, jede Änderung wird erst mal notiert, solange bis sie durchgeführt wird. Und wenn dazwischen irgendwie der Blitz einschlägt, dann weiß man zumindest, was als Letztes zurückgenommen werden muss und den ursprünglichen Zustand wieder herzustellen.
Genau, das gibt es sozusagen als Geom-Modul und das klinke ich zwischen Festplatte und den Schreiboperationen in meinem Dateisystem.
Das heißt, ich kann auch so ein DOS-Fatfile-System nehmen.
Dann machst du da ein Geom dazwischen, dann kommt die Festplatte und dieses Geo-Journal macht für dich das Journaling.
Das ist so super, dann hat man sozusagen Datensicherheit, aber trotzdem noch so das solide 8.3-Dateinahmesystem. Schön. Autoexec.bat, jetzt nicht korrupt. Was ich interessant finde, ist die Option mit Krypto. Ist das quasi auch serienmäßig mit dabei?
Das ist alles, was ich erzählt habe, bei FreeBSD serienmäßig mit dabei.
Das heißt, es gibt da irgendwo so einen Schalter und dann ist auf einmal alles verschlüsselt?
Na, man muss halt sagen, okay, mach mal diese Festplatte, mach da jetzt mal eine Geom-Verschlüsselung drauf, dann sagt man ihm halt ein Key und dann formatiert man diese verschlüsselte Device und dann operiert man darauf ganz einfach transparent, als wäre es ein ganz normales Festplatte.
Und womit verschlüsselt man das dann?
Na, was man halt gerade haben will. Also, welche Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus man da haben möchte, welche Key-Länge man da haben möchte, je nachdem. Das kommt auf das Modul an, was man dazwischen schaltet.
Okay, was möchte man zum Beispiel haben, was nutzt du?
Na, ich benutze zum Beispiel dieses Modul, es heißt Geli und es macht halt AES-Verschlüsselungen, halt irgendwie so der Standard Verschlüsselungs-Cypher. Mit beliebiger Schlüsselgröße.
Okay, aber eine Verschlüsselung braucht immer ein Schlüssel, wo liegt der?
Der Schlüssel, na der liegt sozusagen in diesem, auf dem Device selber, aber ist ja sozusagen, du musst ja deinen Schlüssel sozusagen eingeben. Da gibt es ja einen Schlüssel. Wann, wo? Wenn du sozusagen diesen entkrüpteten Provider mounten möchtest, musst du natürlich vor, deine Passphrase eingeben.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich jetzt, also sagen wir mal. Ich habe da so eine etwas windige Web-Community und ich brauche jetzt da eine passende Forum-Software und ich habe ein gesteigertes Interesse an der Privatsphäre dieser Leute. Und jetzt wissen wir ja, dass so dieses Einreiten in irgendwelchen Hosting-Centern, wenn mal irgendwas fishy ist, sowas kommt durchaus vor und da mag es ja ein Weg sein, die Privatsphäre da etwas vorausschauend zu berücksichtigen, indem ich einfach alles verschlüsselte. Oder würde man nicht, geht das nicht?
Na ich würde zum Beispiel das Betriebssystem selbst nicht verschlüsseln, aber man könnte zum Beispiel so Dinge machen wie, ich nehme mir einen Jail und dieses Jail läuft halt komplett in einem verschlüsselten Container. Man kann also auch Files... Container im Sinne von, ich habe sozusagen so einen 32 GB Blob, der auf der Festplatte liegt. Einfach ein File, was 32 GB groß und Disk Image mäßig ist.
Eine Datei, die ist wie eine Festplatte.
Und dann benutze ich das sozusagen als Festplattendevice und mache da aber eine Verschlüsselung drauf. Und da drin liegen alle Daten, die in diesem Jail drin sind.
Okay, aber jetzt muss ja auch irgendwo der Schlüssel liegen. Wenn ich diesen Server jetzt booter, muss ich dann immer daneben stehen?
Dann den Server nicht, weil das Betriebssystem selber ist ja nicht verschlüsselt. Aber wenn du dieses Jail starten möchtest...
Ja, aber wenn der Schlüssel dann in dem unverschlüsselten Teil liegt, dann ist er witzlos.
Nein, so funktioniert Krypto ja nicht. Du brauchst ja eine Passphrase.
Ja, aber wer gibt die wo ein?
Du als Admin. Wenn du das Jail startest, gibst du diese Passphrase ein. Aus der Ferne. Über SSH, über Remote Lock.
Okay, das heißt, wenn der Rechner... Ich gehe jetzt davon aus, so Bumm, Stromausfall, Maschine ist unten, fährt wieder hoch. Das heißt, der Dienst kann dann nicht automatisch anlaufen, der kann nicht automatisch anlaufen. Bevor nicht irgendjemand mal gesagt hat, tra la la, meine Passphrase ist...
Meine Voice ist meine Passphrase.
Aber ab dem Moment kann dieser laufende Prozess diesen Schlüssel nehmen. Der liegt dann nur noch im Rahmen, oder was? Und kann dann irgendwie diese ganzen verschüsselten Blöcke übersetzen. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo der Rechner ausgeschaltet wird, ist es weg. Und aus dem Regal rausgezogen wird, liegt dann nur noch Bitmüll.
Genau.
Und wie kompliziert ist das, so was einzurichten?
Das sind, glaube ich, zwei Commandlines.
Oh. Nicht viel. Also so zweimal ein bisschen was Längeres mit Minus und Spaces.
Also wenn ich ein Jail mache, dann ist es sogar nur eine Commandline. Da hat ja der gute Erdgeist eine Software geschrieben, die das für mich macht. Die heißt Easy Jail und damit ist so ein Jail kreieren eine Sache von einer Zeile.
Das ist jetzt ausnahmsweise mal etwas, was nicht dabei ist.
Das ist in den Ports.
Aha, okay.
Das heißt, Easy, das schreibt sich, glaube ich, EZ-Jail, genau.
Und das ist jetzt sozusagen eine Script-Sammlung.
Das ist ein Management-Interface zu diesen Jails, mit dem man sozusagen administrativ auf Jails kreieren, löschen, archivieren, kopieren, starten, stoppen, etc.
Also typische administrative Vorgehör nochmal vereinfacht. Das Krypto-Rate in diesem Geom-System. Das sind eigentlich so die wesentlichen Anwendungen, die du auch damit machst, auf deinem System. Also du benutztest zur Daten- Ausfallsicherheit durch Mirrors oder Rates, zur Datensicherheit mit Verschlüsselungen. Sonst noch was?
Backup?
Gibt einem das da auch?
Backups, nicht wirklich, nee.
Noch so Backups?
Ja, ich mach Backups. Den meisten Platz auf den Festplatten verbrauchen wir die Backups.
Okay, das heißt jeder deiner Rechner hat auch selber sozusagen immer noch ein Backup am Start?
Ja, auf dem anderen Rechner sozusagen. Aber den mach ich dann mit wiederum einem Tool, was ich mir geschrieben habe, das dann einfach Simpeltar benutzt. Oder mit R-Sync. Das ist ja alles auch in den Ports dabei.
Ich denke, jetzt haben wir schon mal einen ganz guten Überblick geliefert. Was hast du denn so für, gibt es denn noch irgendwelche Tipps? Also nehmen wir jetzt mal an, das hat jetzt tatsächlich jemand bis zur 74. Minute tatsächlich gehört. Und würde jetzt selber losziehen und sich gerne so ein System machen, was sind noch so Dinge, die du so empfehlen kannst, oder Erwartungen, die man vielleicht nicht haben sollte an so einem FreeBSD-System, wo es irgendwie nicht so gut mitspielt?
Wenn es jetzt im Desktop-Bereich ist, kann ich da nicht so richtig viel sagen, weil ich es halt auf dem Desktop nicht benutze, aber da sollte man vielleicht nicht so die Ansprüche auf den Support irgendwelcher obskurer USB-Audio-Hardware oder irgendwelcher super extremen neuen Grafikkarten legen. Der Support da ist schon relativ groß, aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass jede beliebige Gamer-Grafikkarte, die man da reinsteckt, jetzt wirklich sofort mit 3D-Support und allen Features on funktionieren wird. Vielleicht ist das inzwischen auch so, das kann ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht beurteilen, weil ich das schlicht nicht habe. Server hat keine 3D-Grafikkarte.
Wir haben ja nun schon die ganze Zeit eigentlich den Fokus auf Server gehabt und den sollten wir eigentlich auch behalten.
Aber als Server, würde ich sagen, gibt es da eigentlich nichts, was nicht supportet wird. Auch wenn man sich jetzt sicher Rät-Controller der besseren Sorte, die man auch wahrscheinlich nehmen sollte, weil die billigen halt immer irgendwie Blödsinn bauen, ist auch kein Problem. Die Rät-Controller-Hersteller sind auch aktiv dabei, Treiber für FreeBSD zu schreiben und die immer aktuell zu halten.
Was ist mit Linux-Software, die jetzt nur binär vorliegt?
Da gibt es einen Kompatibilitäts-Layer. Da kann man sich aus den Ports wiederum sozusagen ein Set von Linux-Libraries installieren. Ich glaube, die sind von Red Hat, wenn ich mich nicht ganz eure. Und wenn man die dann installiert hat und sozusagen diese Kompatibilität angeschaltet hat, dann kann man sogar für Linux-kompilierte Software direkt auf dem FreeBSD ausführen.
Aber auch so Sachen, die nicht frei sind, was weiß ich, sowas wie SAP-Kram oder so, könnte man also auch problemlos unter FreeBSD oder zumindest, ich weiß nicht, ob es problemlos sein wird, aber zumindest sollte es laufen.
Mathematika zum Beispiel ist so ein Fall. Da gibt es auch so eine Anleitung und ein FreeBSD-Handbook, wie man das sozusagen Mathematika für Linux unter FreeBSD einfach mal starten kann. Und es ist auch nicht wirklich umfangreich. Es ist relativ einfach. Gut.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Grundlegendes vergessen?
Grundlegendes vergessen?
Bestimmt.
Bestimmt haben wir was vergessen.
Ich mag FreeBSD, weil?
Ich mag FreeBSD, weil es funktioniert.
Okay, das ist doch ein Wort. Wer kann das schon von seinem System so ohne Weiteres behaupten?
Es ermöglicht mir, ruhig zu schlafen mit der Gewissheit, dass es auch morgen noch läuft.
Super, vielen Dank, Cryx, für den Einblick in FreeBSD. Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. Es war ein bisschen technisch, aber ich kriege immer wieder Post, dass das ganz okay sei. Also haben wir das jetzt einfach mal so gemacht. Ich kann euch jetzt auch schon versprechen, es geht so weiter. Wir haben noch ein paar schöne Themen für die Zukunft, aber ich werde die erst mal nicht erwähnen, weil am Ende klappt es dann wieder nicht. Dann habe ich wieder was gesagt, was ich nicht halten kann. Aber trotzdem geht es weiter mit Chaosradio Express, wie gewohnt. Und an dieser Stelle sage ich jetzt erst mal Tschüss. Bis bald.